[Music]
with the potential of a North Korea
summit of the ongoing trade negotiations
with China the Far East region is an
important one for the Trump
administration Victoria Coates it's on
the president's National Security
Council that is here now to discuss the
region and what else is going on around
the world good to see you always good to
see you John
as far as North Korea goes the president
talked about it on his way down to the
NRA convention in Dallas let's listen to
what he said presidents in there
Victoria that he's got a date and the
location so let me see if I can get you
in trouble right off the top here where
and when Moscow no I think that's that's
for the president to announce obviously
as a staff we've been working very hard
on his direction to get this organized
and we're making good progress the
president has said he would like to have
it at peace house in pan moon John I'm
being told by some people at the White
House that that's all well and good but
logistically might be a little difficult
I think pretty much every location is
logistically challenging that has its
own unique set of circumstances it
nothing's off the table nothing's on the
table it'll be his announcement to make
how soon do you think we'll hear about
that I think we'll hear sooner rather
than later what is the u.s. doing to
ensure that this isn't just another ploy
by the latest in successive Kim regimes
to play the United States well we're
actually just trying to learn from
history that we've seen a number of very
well-intentioned attempts to engage the
North Korean regime but we haven't
gotten to the place we've wanted to and
so the president has started by laying a
very clear strategic goal
denuclearization nuclearization which is
a terrible word but that is what he
wants to achieve and he's made that
clear up front that that that's
non-negotiable and we're gonna work back
from there the other thing he said today
I thought was very important was that
our troops in North Korea or South Korea
rather are not something he's willing to
bargain with let me ask you about that
and if you think nuclearization started
to say try to say politicization that's
the really tough one but let me ask you
about the troops the New York Times this
morning said that the president has
asked the Pentagon for options about
drawing down the number of US troops
there the White House pushback on that
John Bolton pushback is that that's not
true but if North and South Korea signed
a peace agreement and North Korea starts
to take steps toward denuclearization is
there still a reason to have 28,500 you
history we'll have to see what that
looks like
and what have to get to that point I
think that's a very important step that
we would mean the president said when at
Andrews I think today that he wants to
get there but he's not going to bargain
over the troops right now he wants to
get to his strategic goal have his
comfort that the security of the - of
the United States is taken care of and
then he'll consider anything like that
but that's that's in the future that's
not something we're looking at now the
president has said that the the goal
here and not just the goal but that the
deal has to be denuclearization
obviously that's his opening bid is
there any way that he would take
anything less than total and complete
dnews I really don't think so I mean we
need to get that program dismantled what
we've seen in recent months from the
North Koreans is a real sea change a
real shift in attitude it's been very
encouraging on a number of fronts but
now we need to see a material
manifestation of that yes we want to
join the international community we
don't need these weapons that's that's
what we need to see we talked about this
offline in terms of the chronology the
next big thing coming up is the May 12th
decision about whether or not to renew
the waivers of sanctions against Iran or
pull out of the jcpoa which way is that
going to go well I mean the president
has been pretty clear about how bad he
thinks this deal is but on Monday we
learned from the prime minister of
israel that it may well be worse how
much did that change the calculation
that it has been a very important factor
the prime minister said that he did
share that information with the
president when he visited in March and
so this is something we've had an
indication of for a while we didn't have
all of the details our people have been
working through it as well as the
Israelis we haven't certainly have not
gone through all of it it's a lot of
huge translation left
but what we've seen we deemed to be
authentic and it's it's deeply troubling
I mean the weather they lied and we
didn't know about it or we kind of knew
it was the case and went into the deal
anyway it was based on a lie and that's
not something I think that's sustainable
a couple of big issues on China our
trade delegation just on the way back
from China with us made demands to lower
the us-china trade deficit by two
hundred billion dollars over two years
the Chinese came back with a set of
demands it sounds in the surface like it
didn't go very well well I mean we've
got to raise these issues I mean the
vital thing is you have a president
who's willing to work with China who has
a strong working relationship with
President G but who's also willing to
say look this is intolerable
the intellectual property issue is
something we're very upset about and
we're going to have to have a series of
difficult discussions and part of the
problem is no one's been having these
discussions for a couple of decades with
the Chinese and they've they've gotten
into a certain mindset and it may take
some time to change but I I don't I
wouldn't say it didn't go well I would
say it was a productive working
discussion one other big issue with
China is China now putting missiles in
the South China Sea on the islands that
it is basically built in the u.s. saying
that it doesn't like that what is the
u.s. willing to do to get those missiles
out of there sighs yeah this has been
another enormous problem that was not
addressed as it was developing so we
inherit a South China Sea with a whole
series of archipelagos that's another
good word and that china is militarizing
and that's not something that we are our
allies in the region are very
enthusiastic about what to do well I
think we're prepared to start pushing
back strongly which hasn't happened
before
and then we'll see what the Chinese are
willing to do I'm not going to predict
some sort of dramatic military action
but but they know that we're serious
Victoria coats that was great to see you
thanks for dropping by thank you
Jonathan do we go you two